[Music]  you people recognize you when you're  just Sasha when you're yourself not  really not really which is which is  great you wanted to see if people would  recognize you if you just yes yes I see  so I went downtown here to see if anyone  recognized me yeah  no makeup no nothing no no just me okay  let's take a look at what happened what  do you think of Sasha Baron Cohen I  don't know you with her [ __ ] even  though I hate this word and I never use  it mf'er he's known as having quite poor  etiquette and bad manners does that turn  you off his babies if there was a ten  Saddam Hussein an eight where would such  Brown Cohn be on that scale of evil  it's point nine  [Applause]  you